chaque semaine de nouveaux produits
alimentaires nous sont proposés sont ils
à prendre ou à laisser aujourd'hui des
doses de jus qui réveille les papilles
des canneberges en mode bonbons santé et
une copie du lait sans produits laitiers
note mais ok
ça goûte bon est-ce que ça goûte le les
harengs tropicale pour moi c'est très
près tous très fort mais j'ai un feeling
de bord de mer et de piña colada c'est
plus sobrement le concept derrière est
vraiment de nous produire ce qu'on
appelle un analogue est donc une copie
du lait et quand je dis une copie déjà
on le voit en termes de couleurs de
textures bons arômes ygout peut-être pas
parfait mais l'intention est là en quoi
ce produit là se distingue-t-il des
autres ce sont près à peu près tous des
ingrédients qu'on pourrait retrouver
dans la cuisine cela dit je vous
garantis que si vous essayez de mélanger
tout seul chez vous vous n'arriverez
jamais à ce résultat c'est à dire grâce
à l'intelligence artificielle ils ont
créé des algorithmes qui permettent
d'aller identifié parmi le règne végétal
quels ingrédients si je les assemble me
permette de rassembler les morceaux du
poison qui d'un point de vue théorique
reconstitue le nez c'est seul concept
derrière donc c'est très pressé et un
des avantages particuliers de ce produit
là par rapport aux autres boissons
végétales qui se retrouvent sur le
marché c'est son utilisation
donc selon ce que l'entreprise moody on
devrait être en mesure d'utiliser ce
produit locke est exactement de la même
façon qu'on utilise le lait donc que ce
soit consommation tels quels ou pour
mousser ou pour faire une recette une
sauce quoi que ce soit en principe le
produit permet une utilisation identique
à celle du litre si on parlait nutrition
comment ça se compare aux audley le
point particulier pour lequel on peut
vraiment pas dire que c'est
ray copie du lait c'est au niveau des
protéines on parle de moins de la moitié
des protéines pour un verre de lait donc
on peut pas considérer cet aliment le
commettant aussi nourrissante que les
hauteurs de pluie se comporte comme ans
je m'attendais qu'un produit comme ça
soit quand même significativement plus
cher que le lait la réalité que c'est
que c'est pas plus cher c'est
sensiblement le même prix que le led
donc c'est un produit qui somme toute
est accessible isabelle à prendre ou à
laisser
je dirais que c'est un produit qui est
particulièrement intéressant pour les
amoureux du lait qui recherchent une
solution végétale sans vouloir faire de
compromis sur le goût sur l'utilisation
qui se trouve à en faire c'est le
substitut ou l'alternative qui d'un
point de vue gustatif dans son ensemble
est le plus intéressant sur le marché
[Musique]
l'omission entreprises québécoises
montréalaise formidable avec une mission
comme le dit dans son nom de lutter
contre le gaspillage des fruits et
légumes dans un bon français ici on ne
rit corps chatte et le booster j'ai pas
d'équivalent français mais bon c'est le
nom du produit c'est le faisons avec en
effet l'idée d'une flotte qui est une
dose en fait est un concept qui est pas
vraiment nouveau le concept est toujours
le même d'arriver à concentrer dans une
petite portion une petite dose certains
ingrédients qui sont reconnus à
différentes grilles pour avoir des
bienfaits pour la santé jusqu'à ce que
l'un d'eux d'un code boussieux on parle
de jus de gingembre de jus de poire de
jus de citron alors que le recovery fait
de jus de curcuma clémentine et poivre à
droite la majorité des agréments qui
sont utilisés dans ses produits le son
des ingrédients qui ont déjà été
étudiées pour certains bénéfices en lien
avec la santé le gingembre par exemple
est reconnu pour avoir un effet
stimulant cela dit plusieurs des
ingrédients qui sont utilisés dans celle
je pense en particulier au curcuma ou au
poivre noir les quelques études qui ont
démontré certains bienfaits potentiels
pour la santé ont été faits avec des
doses ou des concentrations beaucoup
plus élevé que ce qui se retrouve dans
ses produits le connaissait
ça sent bon
ok pas haut c'est très bien
pour moi ce genre de produit là d'où il
est le plus intéressant c'est que c'est
comme un genre de coups de fouet pour
les papilles c'est agréable à boire mais
je m'arrête là donc au niveau des
bénéfices santé n'est pas de preuve qui
permette de confirmer que les bénéfices
ont véritablement la
rue de bondues bonbons maintenant bel
innovation de la part de fruits d'or ici
où on nous propose une carte berges
façon bonbon est vraiment bon ben on
tourne on a vraiment la canneberge
entière ici mais avec le bon petit goût
à la fois un peu sucré et fruité
acidulées d'un bonbon sûr c'est très
bien réussi mais parce que la canneberge
par définition c'est un fruit qui est
très acide amer sur et non pas seulement
2,8 g de sucre pour un sachet complet si
je compare ça à des jeux je bous bonbons
sud c'est 80% moins de sucre qu'un gpu
passé cerise sur
les une carte berges du goût de la
cerise mon cerveau il
ne comprend pas non total après moi mais
on dirait que ça maria mieux la seule
chose qu'on perçoit comme un petit
arrière-goût le jeu c'est qu'est ce que
c'est de glisser rennes a été ajoutée
pour garder les canneberges mobile à
prendre ou à laisser
si
vraiment c'est la première fois que je
goûte à une alternative santé à un
bonbon que je trouve vraiment
satisfaisante mon bémol ces niveaux prix
mais autre chose dans ma maison le
soixante dix pour cela il veut dire
biologique est le fruit en question
vient du québec la compagnie aussi
on ne peut pas pas tant
[Musique]